chers collègues initialement l'article
premier visait à établir un cadre
législatif ou une nouvelle profession
intermédiaire après avoir repris une des
conclusions du ségur de manière peut
être prématuré nous collègues députés en
transformer cet article en une demande
de rapport visant à permettre le
déploiement de l'exercice de la pratique
avancée et les protocoles de coopération
il est évident que la situation actuelle
ne répond pas aux besoins d'évolution en
compétences des professionnels de santé
et c'est pourquoi ce rapport nous semble
essentiel pour poursuivre la montée en
puissance des dés le des leviers définis
dans le plan ma santé 2022
en effet alors que l'accès aux soins sur
le territoire est hétérogène
alors que les protocoles de coopération
n'ont eu connaissance limitée depuis
2009 et que la loi de juillet 2019 a
récemment refondu son cadre juridique
alors qu'un rapport du rapporteur
souligné à 2014 le besoin d'une montée
en compétence et de professions
intermédiaires peu d'analysé existe sur
la situation actuelle et sur les limites
potentiel on connaît le sort
généralement réservé aux demandes de
rapports dans cette assemblée
mais il me semble dommage de se priver
d'éléments analytique alors même que
c'est précisément selon la commission ce
qui faisait défaut dans cette
proposition de loi ce rapport en
complémentarité avec la mission souhaité
lors du ségur permettra une analyse
raisonnée et exhaustive de la situation
actuelle afin de répondre efficacement
aux besoins de simplification du système
de santé où toutes ces raisons l'article
premier nous semble avoir toute sa place
dans ce texte
et c'est pourquoi nous proposons sans
rétablissement et je compte sur votre
vote favorable l avis de la commission
sur cet amendement 159
merci à l'imposante je voudrais dire
notre collègue que nous avons supprimé
cet article en commission pour plusieurs
raisons que j'ai développé à quinze
jours mais que joe bien le développer
aussi ce soir
d'une part la porter cet article est
trop limité au regard des enjeux réels
de revalorisation des métiers de santé
cette demande de rapport n'a pas sa
place dans la loi a fortiori
un article 1er quittant offert une
disposition phare de ce texte une
demande de rapport en arthies premier de
sa ne sommes pas bons d'autre part le
bilan sollicité dans un délai bref de
six mois messieurs de manquer de recul
pour des dispositifs n'ayant pas atteint
leur poids importés ou ont fait l'objet
de réformes récentes les premiers
infirmer de pratiques avancées ont été
diplômés en juillet 2019 et ils sont
actuellement à ce jour 5 149
quant au protocole de coopération leur
cadre juridique a été remis à plat par
éloi santé de juillet 2019
il a encore été modifié par la loi à sap
de décembre 2020 et la présente
proposition de loi ont proposé à son
article 1er une nouvelle évolution
je ne vois pas d'intérêt à réintroduire
cet article sans portée normative et
dont la rédaction à certains égards et
en plus ambiguë
c'est donc un avis défavorable de la
commission quel est l'avis du
gouvernement j'entends et respecte
évidemment les arguments du rapporteur
de la commission en la matière je vais
pas revenir sur le fond de cette notion
de professions médicales intermédiaires
qui n'est certainement pas un médecin au
rabais c'est certainement pas leur jeu
c'est tout le contraire c'est permettre
à la france de disposer de soignants
dont le diplôme serait
quelque part entre un bac + 3 à bac + 12
comme énormément de pays comme la quasi
totalité des pays pour pouvoir aider à
des prescriptions et terrasses qui ne
contrevient pas à la logique des ip a
évidemment auxquelles je crois beaucoup
c'est l'idée de nous faire avancer dans
les pratiques avancées de de se poser la
question de savoir si on n'a pas des
possibilités de permettre à des
soignants de te faire des formations
complémentaires ou par la verve de peu
pouvoir obtenir des compétences
supplémentaires
mais messieurs les sénateurs je confie
une mission au président du conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins au
président du conseil national de l'ordre
des infirmiers une mission
préfiguratrice pour savoir avec en toute
liberté de leur poser la question de
savoir s'ils considèrent qu'il ya de la
place pour ces évolutions dans notre
système de santé
ce qu'ils puissent travailler librement
si à l'issue de cette mission il répond
il n'y a pas de place écoutez on a
réussi cette réflexion je considérais
que la france n'a pas la place pour ce
type de profession intermédiaire là où
elle l'a aux etats-unis au canada en
suède dans plein de pays comprend
souvent en exemple quand on parle de
santé aussi pour l'organisation
si par contre ils disent oui ça peut
être intéressant de creuser on a vu la
profil et les différentes professions on
a concerté large on peut faire évoluer
notre système très bien se poser une
question s'est jamais un drame
au contraire et donc je suis favorable à
ce que ce rapport puisse être remis
publiquement présenté devant le
parlement
ce rapport que je confie aux ordres si
une version qui remise au parlement et
qui est présenté ce sera très bien je
pense que c'est au contraire même très
important donc je suis favorable pour
cet amendement même si cette mission
elle a vocation à vivre sa vie sous la
forme ou non d'un rapport remis au
parlement donc un avis favorable à
l'amendement est surtout un avis
favorable pour qu'on puisse mener cette
réflexion dans un climat de sérénité
je pense que c'est important que ça ne
figure pas dans le marbre de la loi la
création d'une profession intermédiaire
je les dis l'assemblée nationale mais je
pense que c'est important qu'on puisse
avoir cette réflexion
monsieur juillet merci madame la
présidente là je comprends je comprends
la logique
des ministres vous avez idée qui peut
rien y avoir une nouvelle profession
intéressant dans le système de santé
vous d'ailleurs pas la députée qui a
écrit la proposition de loi très bien
c'est très clair au moins et vous avait
missionné des représentants
d'institutions notre système de soins
pour mener une réflexion à ce sujet très
bien mais ça sert à quoi la sete
cet article pardon mais vous n'avez pas
besoin qu'on délibère qu'on vote qu' on
pourrait y avoir un rapport vous avez
créé une mission pourrait
qu'exploratoire donc ne mettons pas la
charrue avant les boeufs cet article 1
vous venez nous le dire était trop
précipité n'étaient pas adaptées dont
acte donc je me je vous félicite pour
cette cette position mais ce rapport n'a
strictement aucun intérêt que vous
vouliez faire plaisir à un parlementaire
très bien mais on va attendre que cette
mission soit mené on en regarde les
résultats et s'il s'avère utile de créer
une nouvelle profession mais je souscris
aux arguments du rapporteur
il ya deux nouvelles professions qui
sont en cours de détermination dans
notre système de santé
les infirmes et pratiques avancées et
les assistants médicaux et dans les deux
cas c'est le cadre conventionnel qui est
en train de travailler vous suivez ces
travaux de près les conditions
d'émergence de ces professions et c'est
très bien comme ça
donc moi je suivrai la position de la
commission très bien à d'autres
explications de vote je vais donc mettre
aux voix la maman 159 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission est
favorable du gouvernement qui est pour
cet amendement qui est contre il n'est
pas adoptée à l'article 2 bis 2
amendement faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 190 de madame
cohen dante nous proposons ici de
reconnaître la place des sages femmes
dans les équipes de soins primaires
en effet les actions de dépistage de
prévention et de
diagnostic de la pathologie effectué par
les sages-femmes les positionne comme
praticienne de premier recours en soins
primaires pour la santé des femmes
ces professionnels sont donc en ce sens
au coeur du dispositif permettant la
patiente d'être au centre du parcours de
santé
cette place dans le système de santé
français nécessite pour nous d'être
clairement identifiés dans la loi d'un
parcours de santé se définit comme la
trajectoire globale des patientes et
usagers dans leur territoire avec une
attention particulière portée à la
personne et à ses choix
le parcours de santé des femmes et
l'organisation d'une prise en charge
globale et continue des individus au
plus proche de leur lieu de vie ou de
travail
la lisibilité l'accessibilité la
fluidité du parcours de santé s'appuie
sur la qualité de l'information des
conditions d'accueil et d'accompagnement
la femme
tout au long de sa vie tous ces
arguments plaident en faveur de la
reconnaissance des sages femmes dans les
équipes de soins primaires et cela
rejoint une fois n'est pas coutume la
philosophie du plan ma santé 2022
en élargissant ici les compétences des
sages-femmes pour ma part comme pour
l'ensemble des membres de mon groupe
cela s'inscrit dans la continuité des
articles précédents visant à améliorer
l'attractivité de cette profession
en travaillant sur plus de valorisation
et de reconnaissance mes chers collègues
cela fait plusieurs mois que les sages
femmes se mobilisent pour que leur
profession je vous le rappelle médicale
et non paramédical soit enfin pleinement
reconnu cet amendement peut y contribuer
et je vous remercie monsieur longs jours
pour l'amendement 46 si madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues les soins dits de
premier recours tels que les actions de
dépistage de prévention et de diagnostic
de distanciation et d'administration des
médicaments contribuer à pallier le
manque de médecins et assurer un
meilleur accès aux soins pour les
français sur l'ensemble du territoire
lady soins sont la plupart du temps
administrée par les sages-femmes
praticienne de premier recours pour la
santé des femmes
cependant les compétences de ces
dernières restent peu connues des
patientes et d'autres professionnels de
santé le présent amendement vise donc à
reconnaître officiellement la
contribution des sages-femmes ses soins
de premier secours
recours contribution qu'ils nécessitent
d'être clairement identifiés dans la loi
tel est l'objet de cet amendement je
vous remercie et l'avis de la commission
sur ces deux amendements
madame la présidente la rédaction de
l'article l 14 11-1 du code santé
publique sur les soins de premier
recours n'exclut pas les sages femmes
cela découle par ailleurs de leurs
missions qui sont définies par les
articles l 41 51 tirs et 1 et suivants
du code de la santé publique a affirmé
ce principe comme le fait l'amendement
48 on est donc peu de portée il ne
paraît pas nécessaire en outre
s'agissant de l'amendement 190 de
dupliquer dans le code sécurité sociale
des dispositions qui relèvent déjà du
code de déontologie de la profession
comme le libre choix de son praticien ou
l'indépendance professionnelle vous
c'est une demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable parce que satisfait invite
du gouvernement
en complément de l'avis du rapporteur
que je partage notamment lorsque le
rapporteur explique que l'amendement est
déjà saisi c'est en pratique parce que
les missions qui incombent aux
sages-femmes son émission qui recoupe
celle des équipes de soins primaires
en réalité dire aussi que dans le ségur
ont vraiment une attention très
particulière j'ai reçu à plusieurs
reprises les représentants de la
profession maietti sienne pour faire
évoluer le cadre de métier le cadre de
compétences et déjà actée dans d'autres
textes de loi vous le savez avec
l'expérimentation puis après je pense
rapidement la généralisation de l'image
et instrumentale par exemple parler
maïeuticien les sages femmes mais aussi
le suivi des femmes qui ne sont pas
forcément enceintes les prescriptions
d'un certain nombre de dégâts main ou
d'actes aux personnes qui accompagnent
les femmes parturientes donc tout ça
montre bien que la profession évolue
mots je suis vraiment totalement
convaincu la place et sasha dans le
système de santé et par ailleurs le blog
de revalorisation pour les sages-femmes
qui exerçant en établissement évidemment
aussi dédié aux sages-femmes et j'ai
demandé parce que dans le travail sur
les grilles salariales
on porte une attention particulière
aussi et après il y aura d'autres enjeux
dans domaine rh notamment limite de
lutter contre les contrats courts dont
sont parfois victimes subissent parfois
trop souvent en tout cas
et s'achève dans certains établissements
voilà on fait vraiment évolué ce cadre
là mais là on va complexifier quelque
chose alors que vraiment le coeur du le
coeur du métier le socle que vous
promets que vous voulez promouvoir à
travers vos amendements ils sont déjà
réalisés dans la pratique proposition de
retrait madame cohen ben écoutez moi
j'ai entendu donc les explications du
rapporteur et du ministre à partir du
moment où effectivement ça semble
satisfait je ne veux nous n'allons pas
maintenir notre moment monsieur mini je
veux juste attirer votre attention sur
une chose parce que vous m'avez enfin
vous avez vraiment semblé avoir à coeur
donc de reconnaître l'importance de
cette profession et je partage tout à
fait ce que vous avez dit j'ai été donc
sollicité par des sages-femmes sur le
fait que dans l'insee elles sont
considérées comme des paramédicaux et ce
qui entraîne finalement au niveau de
leur salaire bien un moindre salaire
donc je pense que elle elle vous demande
de les recevoir sur cet aspect là je
pense que ça serait important vous
puissiez les écouter et voir parce que
chacun se repasse un peu le problème et
c'est très important pour elle donc nous
retirons ses amendements et j'en ai
profité pour faire un appel au ministre
comme vous avez pu le constater et je
vous en remercie par avance
madame cohen a retiré ses amendements
monsieur longeau vous confirmez oui je
retiens c'est un moment au regard des
explications à la fois de la commission
et du et du ministre mais j'espère que
effectivement elles seront entendues et
que ce sera bien appliquée merci oui oui
alesi monsieur le ministre j'ai je
voyais que vous aviez envie d'entrer je
voulais profiter de la concorde pour
pouvoir répondre au cibona me sénatrice
couette d'abord j'ai reçu les
représentants des sages fable notamment
la présence de l'ordre et ensuite j'ai
sollicité saisi bercy sur cette question
du classement de la classification insee
je ne sais pas encore quelle sera la
réponse qui me sera fait ce sera
l'interministériel mais sachez que je
suis bien sur ce sujet bien conscient de
ce que vous soulevez comme points ok je
mets aux voix l'article 2 bis qui et
pour qui compte
il est adopté article 2 pointer un
amendement de
4 de monsieur bonne présidente monsieur
ministre je propose de supprimer cet
article
parce que les articles 4151 1 et 10 du
code de la santé publique définissent
les compétences des sages-femmes et
prévoit que ces dernières sont tenus
d'adresser la femme à un médecin en cas
de situations pathologiques
ce qui est le cas de en cas de suspicion
d'infection paris dst pour la sécurité
des patientes la prescription d'un
traitement curatif doit relever du
médecin seul professionnel a disposé de
la compétence pour prescrire un
traitement curatif et en assumer les
conséquences
je demande donc la suppression de cet
article elle est ici mais sur un porteur
merci madame la présidente l'article
donc de quoi terre a été réécrit
monsieur bonne en commission et nous en
avons aussi reconstruit le champ au
domaine de la prévention des examens de
dépistage des ist pour la femme et son
partenaire en excluant le volet curatif
à savoir le traitement des ist chez les
partenaires cette rédaction apparue la
commission des affaires sociales
équilibré et lui semble donc répondre
aux observations qui sont soulevées par
l'amendement de monsieur bonne c'est
donc une demande de retrait à défaut ce
serait d'avis défavorables monsieur le
ministre monsieur bonne comment
réagissez-vous la demande de retrait du
rapporteur très belle très belle
non non non non j'ai réagi j'ai réagi
parce qu'effectivement la commission a
modifié en disant non pour le partenaire
mais oui pour la personne oui pour la
patiente
or c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre ou
alors j'ai fait confiance totalement au
niveau de la commission et du président
mais j'ai déjà fait confiance tout à
l'heure je sais bien qu'on est dans une
période de confiance au niveau de la loi
mais je voudrais être sûr quand même que
la réflexion aboutissent à la fois pour
l'amendement précédent que j'ai retiré
pour celui là également dont je me
retire très bien monsieur longeau le 49
oui merci
ils madame la présidente monsieur me
disent mes chers collègues les sages
femmes peuvent aujourd'hui prescrire des
actes produits et prestations sur des
listes fixées par voie réglementaire
or ces listes pouvant devenir rapidement
obsolète la patiente serait dès lors
contraint à effectuer une double
consultation
d'abord chez l'as à cheval puis chez le
médecin le présente amendement visant à
supprimer ces restrictions et ouvrir
plus largement mais strictement dans le
champ de compétences des sage-femmes
leur droit de prescription pour
simplifier partout sur le territoire
l'accès aux soins
cet amendement alignerait le régime
applicable aux sages femmes sur celui
des autres professions médicales comme
les chirurgiens dentistes qui disposent
dans leurs champs de compétence d'une
peine faculté de prescription je vous
remercie
quel est l'avis du la commission sur cet
amendement 49 présidente l'article l 41
51 tirs et 4 du code de la santé
publique prévoit déjà que les sages
femmes peuvent presque des dispositifs
médicaux et médicaments selon une liste
fixée par arrêté ainsi ainsi que les
examens strictement nécessaires à
l'exercice de la profession
l'intention est d'ouvrir non plus
largement ce droit de prescription pour
éviter notamment des décalages entre les
textes réglementaires les produits santé
utiles à l'exercice de la profession
mais les conditions restent renvoyé au
pouvoir réglementaire le cadre actuel
tel cas juste et par l'article de 15
pièces à apparu donc à la commission des
affaires sociales se satisfaisant en
outre ces dispositions entrerait en
contradiction avec les autres
dispositions du code de santé publique
encadrant les missions des sages femmes
faute d'un retrait la commission a émis
un avis défavorable à vis du
gouvernement pas en complément de
préciser que l'asm et les sociétés
savantes ont été récemment saisis pour
réviser la liste des médicaments que les
sages femmes peuvent prescrire même avis
que le rapporteur mais selon jours non
non je le maintiens parce que si vous
voulez c'est quand même un vrai problème
d'aménagement du territoire et d'accès
aux soins et
je trouve que c'était une mesure qui
était importante et qui est appliquée
par d'autres professions médicales donc
je le maintiens sommiers pour une
explication de vote pour cet amendement
au fond au fond c'est la question c'est
de savoir si on aligne le droit appliqué
aux sages femmes sur celui d'autres
professions médicales par un pli
chirurgiens dentistes en fait ou si on
avance pas à pas en colmatant et en
ajoutant petit à petit des dispositions
qui permettent aux sages femmes
d'exercer pleinement leurs professions
médicales en santé sexuelle et
reproductive et l'amendement notre
collègue lugo est plutôt donc dans cette
plénitude on va dire d'une profession
qui se revoient reconnaître son droit à
prescription dans ce champ limité de la
santé sexuelle et reproductive donc nous
nous voterons cet amendement je vais
donc mettre aux voix l'amendement 49 qui
a reçu un double avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
ou bien vous fasse
qui compte il est adopté je passe à
l'article 4 bis qui était supprimée il y
à un amendement 161
c'est un non pas pour marquer le coup
mais une réelle nécessité lors de la
crise sanitaire plus de 16000
volontaires non soignants ont proposé
leur aide à quelques semaines auprès de
l'ap-hp
cet élan de solidarité est honorable et
nous devons le soutenir cet amendement
ne va en aucun cas à l'encontre de
centaines d'associations présentes dans
les établissements de santé aujourd'hui
le bénévolat n'est pourtant que peu
encadré législativement actuellement en
effet l'article 6323 retire 1-5 du code
de la santé publique indique que les
centres de santé peuvent bénéficier de
la participation de bénévoles à leurs
activités sont davantage de limite
l'action bénévole n'est pas réglementée
non plus dans les ehpad ou la création
d'une convention de partenariat ou d'une
charte définit les modalités de
l'intervention des bénévoles au sein des
établissements de santé les associations
organisent l'intervention des bénévoles
les nombreux volontaires non soignants
s'ils ne sont pas inscrits dans des
associations sont donc en dehors du
cadre légal actuel
ainsi le rejet du bénévolat individuels
semblent aller à l'encontre de la
situation actuelle dans les centres de
santé et les ehpad afin de prendre en
considération l'agilité souhaité par les
bénévoles individuelle sans pour autant
empêcher dans sa totalité leurs
interventions dans les établissements de
santé
notre amendement vise à rétablir
l'article cad miss avec des ajouts
inspiré de l'encadrement existant dans
l'article 1110 11 du code de santé
publique lors de l'examen en commission
la suppression a été maudit motivé par
le besoin de formation des bénévoles
nous pensons que notre amendement y
répond en effet nous souhaitons que le
bénévolat individuel puissent être
réalisés dans les établissements de
santé en complémentarité avec les
associations et dans le respect des
missions de chacun ainsi en ajoutant une
obligation de formation par les
associations des établissements de santé
humaine
en assurant de la non interférence avec
la pratique des soins médicaux ou
paramédicaux et de l'encadrement par un
référent nous pensons que le bénévolat
individuel pour être soutien important
pour les associations des établissements
de santé et monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président que
j'entends bien ce qu'a dit notre
collègue théophile le bénévolat est un
soutien important pour les associations
et pour l'établissement
l'article 4 bis tels qu'ils étaient mis
en place ne parlait pas du bénévolat
associatif il parlait bien du bénévolat
individuelle et c'est bien pour cela que
nous l'avons supprimée au profit du
bénévolat associatif et nous maintenons
donc cet avis de suppression du
bénévolat individuelle parce qu'il
entraîne beaucoup de problèmes en
particulier des problèmes de
responsabilité de la part de
l'établissement
nous souhaitons nous que le bénévole
puisse être formée par les associations
pour aller ensuite aider les patients
les mâles des médecins etc
donc c'est un avis défavorable faute
d'un retrait
la vidéo est là la ministre oui monsieur
le président nous sommes favorables au
rétablissement cet article d'abord parce
qu'on est favorable au bénévolat à titre
individuel qui est une pratique courante
des établissements de santé et qui a été
particulièrement utile je vous le
rappelle pendant la première vague de
l'aco vite et qui se poursuit depuis
d'autre part par contre le consacrer
dans la loi avait suscité des réactions
vives
dessertenne de certains acteurs
associatifs c'est pourquoi nous y
ajoutons l'encadrement que nous
demandons est là et la formation bien
sûr et cet amendement prévoit un
encadrement d'ailleurs de l'intervention
de ses bénévoles dans le cadre des
établissements de santé
voilà pourquoi la logique veut que nous
rétablissions cet article bien je mets
donc aux voix
madame cohen oui merci monsieur le
président nous nos niveaux de notre
groupe on soutient totalement ce que
vient de dire le rapporteur c'est et on
voit bien qu'à partir du moment où on
s'engouffre sur le bénévolat
individuelle et bien ça ouvre énormément
de problématiques d'encadrement de
formation et madame la ministre a bien
donné un certain nombre d'exigences et
là on est plus sur du bénévolat on est
sûr de l'ubs et risation du bénévolat
et oui c'est peut-être un mot qui vous
déplaît mais il faut prendre les choses
telles que nous en tout cas nous les
internes ou les interprétons et c'est
donc la porte ouverte à beaucoup de
choses donc l'avis de la commission est
particulièrement sage en tout cas cet
avis là et nous soutenons bien mais très
rapidement pour dire que je suis
défavorable à la réintroduction dans cet
art de cette de cet amendement je pense
dès lors deux deux raisons j'ai été
médecin on est encore donatrice en ehpad
et très franchement quand on avait des
bénévoles isolé qui arrivent et moi
j'avais faim c'est plus dangereux que
d'avoir une association que l'on peut
cadrer il ya un problème de
responsabilité
les bénévoles isolés arrivés donner à
boire à l'un à l'autre il faut selon moi
je vous en passe voilà j'ai plein
d'exemples comme ça donc je serais
vraiment défavorables on a des du tissu
associatif qui est qu en encadré avec
une responsabilité un président des
normes et donc j'en resterais à 7 à
cette forme d'association oui
puis rapidement monsieur présent
seulement madame la ministre vous dire
que à l'occasion de l'examen de cet
article et j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer l'association de mon
département et je peux vous assurer
qu'elle prenne cette sympathique comme
un mauvais signe à vraiment prendre de
reconnaissance parce qu'elles
considèrent qu'à gay c'est qu'elles sont
mises de côté au regard de cette
mobilisation
elles se sont engagées depuis des années
sur des programmes de formation
d'accompagnement
elles ont investi au creusot consacrer
du temps et à travers cet article est là
bien on a une paire de reconnaissance
donc le clairement c'est peut-être que
vous pensez mais sur le terrain vous
assurez le site est extrêmement mauvais
merci bon je mets donc aux voileux 161
avec le 161 qui vise à rétablir
l'article 4 bis avec un avis défavorable
de la commission favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour l'amendement
de rétablissement de l'article 4 bis
quai pour ces biens qui est contre
donc l'amendement 161 n'est pas adopté
l'article iv vi reste supprimés et je
fasse à l'article 4 ter avec deux
amendements identiques de suppression le
87 qui le défend je vous en prie madame
leroux donc cet amendement s'oppose à
l'institutionnalisation du recours à
l'intervention individuelle de
praticiens bénévoles dans les
établissements de santé
si nous saluons bien sûr l'élan
solidaire fort qui a permis à des
soignants de venir prêter main forte
dans les établissements de santé en
cette période de crise nous nous
opposons à l'institutionnalisation d'un
statut de médecins sages-femmes et
odontologistes exerçant à titre bénévole
pérenniser ce statut revient à
considérer le bénévolat comme supplétifs
aux carences en ressources humaines
constatée depuis de longues années et
n'est autre que du salariat déguisé
de plus la proposition de loi ne prévoit
pas les conditions de leur intégration
au sein des équipes médicales et du
projet médical d'établissement elle ne
précise pas non plus les conditions
d'engagement ni les modalités
d'encadrement de ces bénévoles
le recours à ces bénévoles ne doit pas
être une réponse pour pallier les
insuffisances de moyens des
établissements de santé donc tel est
l'objectif de cet amendement
merci madame pot n 233 identique
oui merci monsieur le président nous
demandons leur nous également la
suppression de cette ère partie cattin
et je crois c'est surtout déjà pour être
cohérent avec le vote de notre
commission qui a supprimé l'article 4
bis parce que nous avons salué il ya là
une initiative de la commission qui
visait donc à permettre l'intervention
des bénévoles dans les établissements de
santé
donc nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi le
même raisonnement n'a pas été appliquée
pour l'intervention de praticiens
bénévoles la logique est pour nous
strictement la même
et d'ailleurs nous l'avons dénoncé
précédemment nous continuons à la
dénoncer et là en plus on voit bien que
cette logique c'est finalement de gérer
la pénurie de personnel toutes
catégories confondues alors quel est le
sens profond que de permettre à des
passes praticiens bénévoles de venir
dans des établissements là où il ya un
manque d'effectifs depuis des années
des années les soignants le personnel
administratif et technique
alerte sur le besoin de recrutement pour
faire tourner les services et là on leur
propose des personnels bénévoles
je crois que c'est un peu se moquer de 1
pourquoi ce qui est dénoncé dans le
rapport pour l'article 4 bis à savoir
l'ouverture possible à des dérives ne le
serait pas pour cet article à savoir
l'utilisation de bénévoles pour pallier
la pénurie de médecins
c'est sûr que là pour limiter les
dépenses publiques je pense que c'est un
argument assez imparable
je dois rappeler ici que les hôpitaux
aux besoins de cent mille emplois lisez
pas de 200 milles et secteur de l'aide à
domicile de 100000 également des emplois
forme et bien rémunéré pour relancer
l'attractivité
donc on est bien loin du bénévolat c'est
pour toutes ces raisons que nous vous
demandons donc de supprimer l'article 4
ter merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président cet article 4
terre permet de sécuriser l'intervention
pas de bénévoles et de praticiens
bénévoles dans les établissements de
santé y compris le sur des missions
relevant du service public hospitalier
et non seulement dans le cas des
activités dévolues aux associations de
bénévoles cette pratique qui est
marginale on sait bien ne constitue en
rien une réponse adéquate ou même comme
vous suit le supposer un simple
palliatifs au problème de la démographie
médicale à hôpital
elle serait d'ailleurs souhaitable que
ces interventions soient ciblées sur des
missions complémentaires et non en lieu
et place de ce qui est effectué
habituellement par les praticiens
sous cette réserve je ne vois pas
d'opposition à donner un cadre juridique
à cette intervention
donc c'est un avis défavorable
suppression de l'article iv et nous
aurons un amendement suivant partie
amendement 87 et 133 avis défavorable
nous donneront un avis favorable à
l'amendement suivant dans l'ordre
d'abord l'avis du gouvernement sur ces
deux amendements identiques défavorable
pardon
bien donc j'ai deux avis défavorable sur
le 87 le 133 identiques qui est pour et
qui est contre
[Musique]
ces deux amendements sont rejetés et jeu
face aux 80 monsieur janvier merci
monsieur vrai nom donc comme vient de
les exposer ma collègue annie le houérou
cet article pose des questions
importantes si encore l'intervention des
praticiens bénévoles su justifier pour
des tâches très circonscrites et précisé
par l'article mais ça n'est absolument
pas le cas
ces praticiens bénévoles pourront
intervenir à l'hôpital afin je cite le
rapport de participer à l'exercice des
missions générales de ces établissements
et de celle attachée au service public
hospitalier cette même difficile de
faire plus large
deuxième problème les raisons qui sous
tendent cette mesure à savoir
et là je cite les auteurs de
l'amendement assemblée a adopté à
l'assemblée nationale donc c'est le
besoin de renforcer les ressources
médicales des établissements publics de
santé dans l'intérêt du service public
hospitalier et dans le contexte actuel
de la démographie médicale
non cette mesure ne rend pas service à
l'hôpital public
nous en avons longuement discuté à
l'occasion de l'examen du projet de loi
de santé 2019 des mesures à même de
lutter contre la désertification
médicale d'une part et contre la
désertion de l'hôpital public d'autre
part nous venons à nouveau dit dédié
l'article 3 concernant les facteurs qui
expliquent aujourd'hui les difficultés
de recrutement hélas les députés une 10
il est difficile de recruter à l'hôpital
eh bien laissons faire le travail par
des bénévoles
non ces questions ne sont pas simples
elles méritent des réponses qui ne sont
pas simples is cela ne résoudra rien et
en plus c'est incompréhensible pour les
personnels hospitaliers voir un dessin à
leur égard c'est pourquoi les faux d'une
suppression de cet article
notre amendement propose au moins de
mettre un quart de fou basique est
pourtant essentielle qui est d'empêcher
que les contrats conclus avec les
praticiens exerçant à titre bénévole ne
se substituent aux postes d'agents
titulaires laissés vacants
notre position est claire le bénévolat
ne peut
et ne doit se substituer au recrutement
de personnels de santé et donc je ne
doute pas que l'avis du gouvernement
sera favorable car ce n'est pas son
intention nous dit-il de substituer des
professionnels de santé les hôpitaux par
des bénévoles
donc avis de la commission c'est un avis
du gouvernement défavorable il ya deux
types de situations différentes celle
des bénévoles non professionnels qui
viennent aux côtés des soignants et
assurer des missions de soutien
d'animation et celle des bénévoles
professionnels de santé qui viennent
assurer des missions de soi en
complémentarité des équipes en place
dans les deux cas ces interventions sont
encadrés par des conventions avec
l'établissement concerné contrairement à
ce que vous affirmez ne s'agit en aucun
cas de pallier une pénurie de moyens
mais plutôt de répondre à une volonté
d'engagement citoyen qui honore
finalement ces bénévoles individuel donc
voilà je pour ces raisons je ne peux pas
être favorable à votre amendement très
bien donc oui si madame la ministre je
vous ai bien entendu vous dites que ça
n'est en aucun cas la volonté du
gouvernement de se substituer à des
professionnels alors à ce moment-là vous
approuver l'amendement de repli de nos
collègues puisque simplement il précise
les choses et c'est extrêmement positif
pour la loi que de préciser les choses
et c'est ce que vous venez de dire en
expliquant votre point de vue donc vous
le partagez vous devriez soutenir cet
amendement de repli qui simplement
précise
elle les missions de chacun et de
chacune jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'est quand même la ministre qui donne
son avis et l'avis est défavorable bien
donc sur l'amendement 80 avec un avis
favorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui et pour qui compte
l'amendement est adopté à l'article 10
l'amendement 138 c'est ben cohen oui
merci monsieur le président l'intérim
médical est un vrai problème et nous le
savons bien
lors de notre tour de france des
hôpitaux et des et pas de public avec
l'ensemble de mon groupe nous avons pu
rencontrer tous les personnels et
notamment les directeurs et les
directrices d'hôpitaux et vraiment il
passe des heures et des heures à essayer
de régler le problème du manque de
personnel et notamment au niveau des
médecins et il s'arrache un peu les
cheveux si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
face aux demandes qui sont faites par un
personnel intérimaire qui effectivement
demande en termes de rémunération des
salaires extrêmement important donc il
faut trouver effectivement une solution
à l'intérim médical mais ça veut dire
aussi identifié identifier les causes
alors je sais qu'il y a eu et nous en
avons discuté ici même dans l'hémicycle
il y a eu des dés
des mesures qui ont tenté d'être prises
pour essayer d'encadrer les choses mais
sont largement insuffisantes et donc si
on sanctionne ces directeurs et ses
directrices d'hôpitaux qui se débattent
dans des situations extrêmement
difficiles parce que ils n'ont pas de
personnel médical en leur faisant encore
peser la responsabilité
ça va aggraver les conditions de des
établissements publics de santé ça va
aussi
donc aggraver la pénurie en personnel
donc je sais c'est le sens évidemment de
notre de notre amendement et revenir aux
sources et à dire qu'il ya effectivement
besoin d'embauchés dans les hôpitaux
c'est ce que porte l'ensemble des
personnels toutes catégories confondues
c'est la revalorisation de leur
profession
et c'est également la revalorisation
salariale les accords de ségur ont été
un tout petit tout petit pas assez
inégalitaire d'ailleurs mais c'est
beaucoup plus qu il faut qu il faut
mettre qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre
puisque vous savez que les personnels
demandait le rattrapage du gel du point
d'indicé à 3 ans 300 euros net
c'est l'augmentation était de 183 euros
ça veut dire que dans le public les
personnels ont moins perdu 120 euros en
dix ans de pouvoir d'achat
donc on voit bien là les difficultés
donc nous demandons par cet amendement
qui n'est pas une double peine qui sont
aux hôpitaux et plus tôt donc de trouver
une solution qui va permettre de régler
davantage cette cette difficulté
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur commission a émis un avis
défavorable à ces amendements parce
qu'il supprime en fait un article
qu'elle a complètement et intégralement
réécrit istra défavorable
de faire madame cohen pour explication
de vote enfin je comprends qu'on puisse
être défavorable par rapport à nos à nos
amendements c'est le sait le jeu au
niveau du parlement d'avoir chacun des
positionnements
ceci dit le problème que nous soulevons
et qui est partagé c'est la gravité de
la situation des hôpitaux la pénurie du
personnel et les pros l'intérim et c'est
vraiment un problème et je pense que mes
collègues ici présents s'ils sont allés
dans les hôpitaux ce que je pense ils
ont pu rencontrer les directions et les
directions appel au secours
alors seulement dire qu'on est dit
favorable à un amendement mais n'a porté
aucune solution
je trouve que c'est un peu court cr
s'est soulevée à la limite l'amendement
peut ne pas être bon mais l'amendement
ouvre un débat et j'aimerais que ce
débat puisse effectivement être nourris
d'ailleurs je me réjouis du fait que
lors de la présence du ministre de la
santé nous avons pu avoir sur un certain
nombre de sujets des débats qui nous ont
enrichi nous n'étions pas d'accord mais
au moins le débat a montré pourquoi le
gouvernement adoptait telle ou telle
position est là le problème vraiment qui
est soulevé c'est comme c'est comme tout
à l'heure quand ma collègue cattier
apourceau poly aa a posé le problème de
delà des drs et des sanctions
financières balayé d'un revers de main
en disant non ça va pas ok d'accord mais
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
proposez je ne parle pas du rapporteur
de la commission avec qui j'ai des
accords et parfois des désaccords
chacun verra ce qui est le plus fréquent
mais où il ya eu un travail de
réécriture
certaines fois que j'ai partagée avec
mon groupe deux fois non c'est pas ça
mais là en soulevant ce problème là je
pense qu'ils intéressent l'ensemble des
parlementaires et plus largement au delà
de nos de notre petite sphère je dirais
et bien l'ensemble du monde de la santé
donc je souhaiterais quand même que ce
débat soit un tout petit peu nourris
même si on est prêts on est pressé par
le temps mais c'est ça le débat c'est ça
le rôle du parlement a su recoller
monsieur chasse un oui merci monsieur
président même le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur présidente vont effectivement
moi je voterai pas ce rapport mais
n'empêche que quand même c'est
effectivement la vérité lorsque on va
dans les hôpitaux on se rend compte que
certains médecins notamment urgentistes
sont embauchés seulement ils veulent ça
va être embauchée à 60 70 % parce que
30% ici ou là ils vont faire de
l'intérim s'ils étaient davantage payé
pour les gardes
ben il cirait pas faire d'intérim festin
exemple si vous voulez cet exemple on
peut dans le médico social
on a effectivement énormément de
problèmes de carences au niveau
d'infirmières et on arrive à trouver des
infirmiers en intérim parce que bien sûr
et sont beaucoup plus payer donc je
pense qu'une des choses pour limiter
l'intérim c'est que les les personnes le
personnel est notamment personnel
médical qui fait des gardes comme les
urgences où les médecins anesthésistes
belles soient davantage de rémunérer
pour les gardes
merci madame poncet mange merci monsieur
le président j'avais eue a effectivement
évoqué ce sujet au moment de la de la
déclaration générale
il est vrai qu'il y a par cet article
une injonction quand même paradoxal et
plus que ça vraiment une
on dit souvent que la maltraitance et
qu'on ne laisse à la personne où l
institution que le choix entre deux
solutions également négative et nous
sommes là dans un cas quand même de
maltraitance qui peut effectivement
peser sur le chef d'établissement
on lui demande la continuité du service
voilà notamment
de maternité excédera de cergy dans
certains territoires et par ailleurs on
lui bloque effectivement à juste titre
c'est sûr que sur facturations
mercenaires des praticiens enfin des
propositions au des soignants mais aussi
effectivement des sociétés intérimaire
donc je pense qu'il faudrait quand même
d'abord que la rs dans tous les
territoires contrôler le fait que tout
le monde applique cette règle parce que
si tout le monde applique cette règle
dans la sphère publique mais dans la
sphère privée ne rêvons pas et bien
effectivement ça assèche de toute façon
l'offre de mercenaires ou à minima que
devant la contradiction entre continuité
du service ou entorse à la discipline
budgétaire
et je pense les deux de toute façon pas
en contentieux pour le directeur est
bien là et reste elle prenne ses
responsabilités et qu'elle prenne pas
ses responsabilités comme l'a dit
laurence cohen trop contente de fermer
les services les maternités les sites de
proximité c'est à dire qu'elles
résolvent effectivement le problème de
la valorisation des gardes
et puis pas seulement puisque dans
l'intérim je le dis en lors de
déclarations générales
il y a aussi des soignants qui
choisissent à pour maîtriser leur temps
leur temps de travail et l'articulation
avec
leur vie familiale sociale ils le font
effectivement parce que dans l'hôpital
et bien du fait des contraintes
constamment ils sont obligés de faire
des heures supplémentaires etc
donc il n'ya pas que l'aspect il ya
l'aspect conditions de travail merci je
déconne agilement la ses demandes au
gouvernement qui règle le problème
merci et 36 chers collègues donc je vais
mettre aux voix
cet amendement 138 avec un double avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 51 madame préville merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement a été travaillé avec les
professionnels que sont les directeurs
d'hôpital et notamment directeurs
d'hôpitaux et notamment selon territoire
rural
c'est à dire l'hôpital de figeac dans le
lot il illustre la crainte très forte
que cet article 10 ans l'état ne mène
assez rapidement à une conséquence
particulièrement délétère voir c'est à
dire la fermeture des services et ceci
dans des contextes très conflictuelle
car en l'état dès qu'il s'appliquerait
les territoires ruraux qui sont peu
attractifs au regard de certains
praticiens notamment urbains qui veulent
bien venir dans nos campagnes sous
conditions des mollets des émoluments
conséquents
eh bien ces praticiens ne viendrait tout
simplement plus et ceci se produirait de
façon brutale parce que dans les faits
c'est ce qui va se passer cet amendement
propose de ne pas passer par une
judiciarisation maps mais par un
ajustement des rémunérations qui
pourrait s'opérer par le comptable
public
il préconise de permettre aux agences
régionales de santé et parce que quelque
part c'est un peu leur rôle d'établir un
état des lieux du respect des conditions
fixées par la réglementation concernant
les rémunérations des praticiens
réalisant des vacations ou facturés par
les entreprises de travail temporaire
je vous remercie merci cher collègue
monsieur le rapporteur
c'est aussi la réécriture de l'article
10 qui avait été écrit par la commission
sociale avis défavorable ron monsieur le
ministre
défavorables aussi monsieur daumier
merci monsieur le président madame
madame prévu notre collègue soulève une
problématique de nouveau sur le même
sujet en expliquant les conséquences du
vote de l'article 10 je veux dire avec
beaucoup de respect aux rapporteurs que
nous dira simplement que la commission
n'a pas écrit ça comme article assez
quand même une argumentation bon on
pourra avoir un débat un peu plus un peu
plus fouillé sur la question surtout on
a tous de la mémoire et nous souvenons
qu'il ya après tout peu de temps agnès
buzyn avait fait de cette lutte contre
cet intérim médical qu'elle qualifiait
de mercenariat une priorité et nous a
fait adopter des dispositions en disant
voilà là on va pouvoir cadrer les choses
dix-huit mois après on se rend compte
que cette inopérant je lui ont fait part
à leurs proches
mais on pourrait tout de même accepté et
argumenter sur le fait que ça risque de
mettre en difficulté des hôpitaux et que
je souscris à ce qui a été dit sur cette
double injonction qui est extrêmement
dur pour certains établissements
oui c'est la loi de l'offre et de la
demande quand il ya pénurie
il ya des personnes qui font des
affaires sur cette pénurie
eh bien vous ne réglez pas le problème
de la pénurie en simplement excluant ou
interdisant à ces personnes de
travailler ça ne fonctionne pas ça ne
fonctionne dans aucun domaine et nous le
savons tous ou alors sinon on va avoir
de nouveaux débats économiques dans cet
hémicycle qui auront une tonalité
singulièrement différente donc dans le
domaine de la santé oui il ya des
personnes qui profitent indûment et il
faut faire un câlin un travail de
cadrage et ce travail de cadrage la
réponse qui est donnée là dans la
réduction l'article 10 mai la rédaction
du gouvernement était pas plus
satisfaisante ne nous convient pas ne
nous convient pas parce que simplement
un risque d'avoir pour conséquence ça a
été dit d'interdire des activités sans
qu'il y ait de substitution sans qu'il y
est
d'autres solutions est donc cet article
10 ne voteront pas dans cette dans cette
rédaction
merci chers connaît monsieur chasse à
monsieur le président chers collègues
moi je voterai pas ce talent normes je
m'abstiendrai parce que effectivement il
est il est certain que dans certains
petits établissements
les personnes par exemple qui sont de
garde aux urgences on 200 je crois de
cent vingt ou trente euros de garde pour
la nuit et donc emphatique et h2 pas
être embauchés à 100% pour aller dans
d'autres hôpitaux pour faire des gardes
d'un 1500 ou voilà et donc si il ya des
sanctions et bien malheureusement et il
en faut je suis d'accord mais il faut
aussi que la rs puisse contrôler et et
voir les possibilités pour les petits
hôpitaux de survivants merci monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur prison joué juste
répondre à bernard jomier sur l'article
10 il ya trois amendements qui
reviennent sur la réécriture dont un
amendement du gouvernement qui revient
lui qui demande à ce qu'on reprenne à
écriture qui a été adoptée
internationale donc je ne voulais pas
faire trois réponses identiques à chaque
fois et j'avais réservé ma réponse au
gouvernement
merci monsieur le rapporteur donc je
mets ouvre à l'article l'amendement 51
avec un double avis défavorable qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté deux amendements
discussion commune 129 du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vais prendre quelques
minutes parce que c'est vraiment un
point clé de cette proposition
parlementaire de loi et je voudrais
vraiment quand en échangeant
je ne désespère pas d'arriver à vous
convaincre de revenir à la rédaction
initiale de cet article 10 en 2012
j'avais commis un rapport comme
parlementaire sur les dérives de
l'intérim médical dans les
établissements de santé est un sujet qui
n'était pas encore n'avait pas
complètement immergé ils étaient cachés
et pour cause vous aviez la des hôpitaux
qui de manière à éviter la fermeture des
blocs opératoires en catastrophe le
week-end de manière à pouvoir continuer
d'endormir les malades de manière à ne
pas fermer un service d'urgence avait
pris l'habitude mais contrainte et
forcée faute de recruter des médecins
sur des postes stables de passer par des
agences d'intérim ou des contrats de gré
à gré d'ailleurs extrêmement onéreux
extrêmement onéreux avec des des
velléités de rémunération hors norme
cela a créé plusieurs effet d'abord la
lassitude des équipes qui voyait des
praticiens hospitaliers quitter leur
contrat de praticiens hospitaliers et
postulez dans le même hôpital avec des
contrats de gré à gré pour gagner en une
semaine ce qu'ils gagnent en un mois ça
entraînait le recrutement massif de
médecins étrangers par des filières de
boîtes luxembourgeoise qui fait rentrer
des médecins dont honnêtement il
arrivait du jour au lendemain dans un
hôpital il ne connaissait ni le système
d'information ni les équipes est arrivé
parce qu'il fallait qu'il ya un médecin
à cet endroit là pour pas fermer un bloc
ça a pu poser des problèmes et des fois
où les médecins sont très grande qualité
d'ailleurs souvent des médecins qui sont
très expérimentés des fois où la qualité
n'a pas toujours été au rendez vous
c'est ce que j'ai énoncé dans le rapport
à l'époque j'ai estimé que c'était 500
millions d'euros de surcoût par an ça
concerne est l'équivalente 5000 médecins
avec un effet d'entraînement massif dans
certaines disciplines
ce rapport il préconisait plusieurs
mesures qui n'ont pas été mises en place
par le gouvernement précédent et j'ai
été le premier à le regretter faisant
partie de la majorité précédente
il s'agissait notamment de plafonner
niveau de rémunération de dire les
règles sont les mêmes pour tout le monde
vous pouvez recourir à l'intérim est
hors de question de payer des sommes
totalement totalement irresponsable
quand ma prédécesseure est arrivé en
2017 elle a pris le décret elle a sorti
le décret c'est a déjà un long combat
disant on va plafonner progressivement
la rémunération de quoi parle-t-on quand
on entend le plafond mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs on parle de 1000
100 euros 1200 euros pour une garde à
l'hôpital c'est le tarif légal 1200
euros quasiment un smic pour 24 heures
de travail à l'hôpital
on n'est donc pas en train de dire qu'on
paye au lance-pierre des médecins qui
ferait des maîtres des missions
d'intérim vous dire qu'entre 2012 est
aujourd'hui l'intérim s'est profondément
accentuée dans notre pays ils touchent
davantage de discipline
il concerne aussi des chu désormais et
que c'est un véritable problème je vous
dire j'ai encore une boîte mail au chu
comme neurologue et pourtant neurologue
c'est pas le forcément la discipline la
plus recherchée
j'ai reçu il ya pas si longtemps que ça
une offre pourrait effectuer une mission
de courte durée où on me payaient
l'équivalent de 2000 euros nets pour 24
heures
2000 euros nets auxquels vous ajouter
parce que c'est un travail précaire une
prime de précarité d'un pur sang auquel
vous ajoutez des avantages en nature
tels que des avantages alimentaires des
avantages de transport or à l'époque
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de directeurs
d'hôpitaux ils disent exactement ce que
vous dites
les directeurs d'hôpitaux me disait on
est pris à la gorge moi si je ne paye
pas le médecin ne vient pas je ferme mon
blog je suis obligé de payer et je le
fais en irrégularité je sais que c'est
irrégulier et il ya du contrôle par les
chambres régionales derrière qui passe
et qui disent bon vous n'avez pas le
choix va pas vous traduire devant un
tribunal administratif certains l'ont
fait à bas bruit et certains directeurs
ont été condamnés à titre symbolique
souvent mais avec une condamnation quand
même parce que il n'avait pas d'autre
choix que de recruter des médecins hors
de prix de la veille du jour au
lendemain
certains directeurs m'ont dit qu'ils
recevaient parfois un coup de fil du
médecin qui devait venir le samedi le
vendredi 11 ans
l'hôpital qui est à 50 km il me propose
un peu plus ce qu'est ce qu'on fait je
ne dis pas que c'est la règle
je ne dis pas que c'est la règle il ya
des médecins encore une fois qu'ils
exercent de la mission de courte durée
c'est important pour remplacer des
congés des départs etc
mais il ya une pratique tarifaire qui
est devenu totalement déraisonnable à
l'époque c'était 1300 euros en moyenne
pour 24 heures aujourd'hui on atteint
fréquemment les 2500 dans les trois
mines il faut que ça s'arrête
les mesures qui ont été prises en 2017
et est importante elle n'était pas
suffisante puisque en mettant en place
un plafond réglementaire
de rémunération avec contrôle a
posteriori ce qu'on constate c'est que
il ya des hôpitaux qu entre guillemets
jouer totalement le jeu il ya d'abord eu
d'ailleurs un mouvement de boycott de la
part d'un syndicat sans visage mais qui
avaient décidé de boycotter un certain
nombre d'hôpitaux qui ne refuseraient de
les payer au prix qu'ils exigeaient bon
jour là le côté éthique de la chose et
d'autres établissements qui continuent
dire écoutez on n'a pas le choix donc
toute façon si c'est pas nous qui me
prononcer l'hôpital là bas ou la
clinique du show du coin donc on est
obligé de payer
et puis voilà et tant pis pour le
plafond réglementaire
je le rappelle 1200 euros c'est pas rien
pour pour 24 heures de travail
ce qu'on propose là on sait je dirais le
larmes ultime ultime pour faire en sorte
que plus personne ne puisse je dirais
jouer ce jeu de la surenchère quand bien
même ce jeu des surenchères seraient
imposées par les conditions sanitaires
locales une règle qui ne peut pas s'être
détournée contourner et qui est la même
pour tout le monde fait que ce mouvement
va s'arrêter
si vous dites il n'y a plus aucun
établissement de santé qui peut payer au
delà du tarif réglementaire un médecin
pour une mission de courte durée je vous
le dis le mouvement expansionniste de
l'intérim va se tarir va se tarir
et le seul moyen d'en être sûr le seul
moyen d'empêcher que les règles soient
contournées en catastrophe par un
directeur parce qu'il aura encore une
fois pas le choix je n'incrimine pas
c'est que le directeur puisse dire à l'
agence d'intérim ou qui le directeur
puisse dire aux médecins qui vient de
voir gré à gré en lui demandant 3000
balle sinon il vient pas je peux bien
vous les crocs m mais je ne pourrai pas
vous les versets je ne pourrais pas vous
les versets c'est impossible vers le
chèque ne partira pas donc si vous
voulez venir travailler vous êtes le
bienvenu ses 1200 euros c'est le tarif
réglementaire 3000 euros vous ne
trouverez nulle part ni dans mon hôpital
ni dans celui qui est à 20 km dit denis
dans celui qui est à 200 km personne ne
pourra vous payer puisque le chèque ne
partira pas c'est du contrôle a priori
c'est du contrôle a priori et en plus
vous entre guillemets vous enlevez
l'épée de damoclès qui pèse sur les
épaules d'un directeur d'hôpital puisque
de toute façon il voudrait il compte
revenir et ne pourrait pas le faire
c'est très important je vous assure ça
fait près de dix ans que je travaille ce
sujet là avec la fh avec lady avec les
hôpitaux avec les médecins
avec avec les syndicats c'est
fondamental il n'y a pas d'autre moyen
d'arriver à tahrir cette expansion
d'intérim et ses méfaits sur les
systèmes hospitaliers et des l'hôpital
c'est vraiment considérer que c'est la
mesure qu'il faut qu'on prenne ça et
vous savez on parle de plusieurs
milliers de médecins qui continueront
d'exercer certains d'ailleurs ils
retrouveront peut-être un poste de péage
tant mieux d'autres continueront sur des
missions de gré à gré mais ça coûtera
moins cher
il faut qu'on arrête de considérer comme
irrémédiable qu'un hôpital est un
déficit annuel équivalent au c'ur
dépenses liées à l'intérêt médical
je peux vous donner une liste d'hôpitaux
dont le tout les déficits l'incapacité à
innover l'incapacité à mieux payer ces
soignants l'incapacité à se moderniser
et lié uniquement à ces sur des temps ce
lien atterri médicale
il faut qu'on arrête il faut qu'on
arrête ce que vous proposez dans votre
rédaction en commission au sénat qui est
intéressant ça ne va pas assez loin on
reste dans la même logique que celle qui
était en vigueur jusqu'à présent qui n'a
pas fonctionné pas suffisamment
fonctionnez vous dit on va intégrer dans
les comptes dans le prd les dépenses
d'intérim et derrière il y aura un
contrôle post qui pourra poste qui
pourra être fait éventuellement on
pourra aller jusqu'au tribunal
administratif mais c'était c'est
exactement ce qui existe aujourd'hui
le directeur vous dire écoutez moi j'ai
pas le toit en plus un direction
d'hôpital peut tout à fait ils savent le
faire j'avais vu dans mon rapport
ils peuvent tout à fait maître la
comptabilité des sur des postes
d'intérim dans un titre ou un autre de
leur dépense de leur comptabilité
donc vous ne verrez pas ça ne se fera
pas au visage que tel de ten directeur
août à l'hôpital à payer 3000 balle par
garde tel médecin un certain nombre de
fois c'est invisible
c'est totalement noyé cette c'est
totalement noyé vous pourrez pas les
montrer donc je veux dire si vous voulez
lutter vraiment avec efficacité contre
l'intérim j'espère vous convaincre qu'il
faut un contrôle a priori et que c'est
comme ça qu'on mettra fin à ce fléau
si honnêtement vous ne pensez pas que le
contrôle a priori soit adaptée ça veut
dire que par là même c'est votre droit
vous reconnaissez qu'il faut conserver
la possibilité pour un directeur de
surpayer des gens et si vous considérez
que un directeur peut continuer à
surveiller les gens et bien je peux vous
le dire
ils continueront à le faire est de plus
en plus monsieur le ministre
alors en discussion commune l'amendement
138 monsieur daumier merci monsieur le
président donc cet article entend
traduire dans la loi une des
recommandations du ségur de la santé qui
visait effectivement à lutter contre
l'intérêt médical
le texte apporte des pressions
budgétaires pour les deux dispositions
concernées d'abord le montant journalier
des dépenses susceptibles d'être engagés
au titre du travail temporaire doit
obligatoirement figurer à le perdre et
ça a été dit deuxièmement le directeur
général de la rs6 constate que ce
montant dépasse le plafond défini par
décret et renvoie le perdre et aux
directeurs d'établissements et réserve
son approbation jusqu'à ce que ce
montant sera inférieur au plafond
à l'issue de l'exécution du budget de
l'établissement si le compte financier
fait apparaître un dépassement du
plafond
le dg de la rs devra déféré au tribunal
administratif
tous les actes qui lui seront
communiqués à sa demande par le
comptable public de l'établissement par
lesquelles l'établissement ait eu
recours au travail temporaire et il en
avisera sans délai le conseil de
surveillance de l'établissement
ces deux dysfonctionnements relevant de
ses compétences nous demandons
simplement que le déontologue de
l'hôpital soit informé au même titre que
le directeur d'établissement et le
conseil de surveillance cet ajout de
modifier en rien le process établis par
ailleurs par le rapporteur et dont il
vient d'être discutée merci cher
collègue monsieur le rapporteur l'avis
de la commission sur ces deux
amendements
merci le président je voudrais d'abord
dire à monsieur ministre olivier verront
que nous avons évidemment pris
connaissance de son rapport du rapport
du député olivier ferrand l'époque de
2012 qui n'était pas un rapport là comme
pour la commission des affaires sociales
mais rapport pour le groupe socialiste
et juste comme ça aussi pour détendre
l'atmosphère
le titre était intéressant puisque
c'était hôpital cherche mais ça coûte
que coûte et non pas quoi qu'il en coûte
je suis complètement d'accord là dessus
cela dit donc maintenant pour revenir à
notre argumentaire notre position sur
certains articles tels que vous proposez
monsieur mist ne repose évidemment pas
sur la finalité c'est une évidence
sinon c'est en effet on aurait tort mais
c'est notre position c'est sur la
méthode le contrôle comptable et le
contrôle budgétaire présente la
distinction notable d'intervenir à des
stades différents de l'engagement de la
dépense de l'établissement le premier
permettant de liquider la dette de
l'ordinateur vis-à-vis d'un prestataire
ayant vous déjà fourni un service et le
second c exerçant en amont de
l'engagement afin d'en vérifier la
régularité
le dispositif initial de l'article 10
donc attribué au comptable public dont
je rappelle qu'il est un agent du
ministère du budget une mission qui
relève normalement du contrôle a priori
du directeur de la rs liées au rôle que
tout représentant de l'état dans un
territoire doit exercer au regard de
l'application de la loi
cette déresponsabilisation n'a pas paru
à la commission des affaires sociales
souhaitable donc émis un avis
défavorable à l'amendement de
rétablissement du gouvernement en
souhaitant évidemment que nous puissions
tous ensemble vous discuté dans le cadre
da cmp et sur l'amendement 138
rapporteur même avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre sur l'amendement
130 en discussion commune défavorable à
l'amendement 130 alors madame un
pourceau pauli a demandé la parole je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre le
constat que vous faites est tout à fait
vrai sur l'intérêt médical et une fois
n'est pas coutume mais je partage le
constat que vous faites
d'ailleurs lorsque je rencontre les
hôpitaux dans mon département le pas de
calais il nous parle évidemment de ce
problème qu'ils rencontrent avec les
boîtes d'intérim qui sont évidemment qui
pratique et qui ont des tarifs qui sont
complètement exorbitant et je pense que
on ne peut plus continuer comme ça alors
il ya quand même deux problèmes de fond
à sa bien évidemment un directeur peut
recourir à l'intérim puisque de toute
façon quand on est face à une situation
on est bien obligé de la régler mais est
ce que c'est les directeurs que l'on
doit finalement sanctionné ou est ce les
agences d'intérim qui pratiquent ce
genre de situation je pense qu'il
faudrait quand même réfléchir en amont
ou en aval pour qu'il y ait d une loi
qui interdise finalement aux boîtes
d'intérim de pratiquer ce genre de
situation parce que ce ce n'est quand
même pas possible qu'elle puisse faire
ce qu'elles veulent
on sanctionne aujourd'hui les directeurs
d'hôpitaux alors moi j'entends bien ce
que vous dites si plus aucun directeur
ne le fais et n'accepte ce genre de
situation ça ne se fera plus mais je
pense pas que ce soit aussi simple que
ça je pense vraiment qu'il faut encadrer
les agences d'intérim et puis ensuite un
mois j'arrête deuxième souci je pense
que on ne prend pas en compte dans ce
genre de réflexion le manque de
personnel qu'il y a dans les hôpitaux et
que si forcément il y avait plus de
personnel dans les hôpitaux publics
eh bien les directeurs auraient moins
recours à l'intérim et les salaires
seraient encadrés voilà merci michael
oui je vais je vais abondé dans le sens
de ma collègue et puis dire à monsieur
le ministre qui n'était pas en séance
tout à l'heure que j'apprécie vraiment
l'intervention qu'il a fait parce que
c'est une intervention qui est pour le
coup qui colle bien à la réalité de
l'hôpital et des difficultés dans
lesquelles se débattent les directeurs
d'ailleurs et les directrices d'hôpitaux
et puis l'inflation sur l'intérim
moi je me rappelle vraiment de
témoignage du directeur et de directrice
qui me disaient mais c'est pas possible
c'est y pas d des heures des jours à
essayer de régler le problème parce que
c'est inflationnistes et les demandes de
salaire sont énormes
donc voilà le constat nous nous le
partageons mais je veux redire ici que
l'inquiétude que nous avons c'est que
face à la démographie médicale
le manque quand même de praticiens le
fait d'avoir recours à ce genre de
mesure où j'entends bien
à partir du moment où on va on va
pratiquer cette façon là eh bien on va
tarir
je ne suis pas tout à fait tout à fait
convaincu je n'en suis pas tout à fait
convaincu pourquoi parce que il y à ce
manque de professionnels et je pense que
si on peut effectivement adopté ce genre
de mesures il faut parallèlement créer
les conditions pour d'attractivité pour
l'hôpital c'est à dire il faut
parallèlement effectivement faire en
sorte qu'il y ait à nouveau une
appétence pour venir travailler à
l'hôpital avec des conditions de travail
différentes avec un salaire différent
avec une revalorisation des ddd
profession d'une manière générale je
crois que ça va obligatoirement de pair
si on ne fait pas ça ça ne marchera pas
et puis mon souci c'est une question
c'est à dire que est ce que finalement
dans la façon dont vous avez rédigé
proposer votre amendement il y a si j'ai
bien compris il ya finalement au bout du
bout une sanction contre les directeurs
et les directions lé directeur elle est
donc je veux dire que ça ça me semble
quand même un peu radical merci cher
collègue madame dit l'otan oui merci à
monsieur le président c'est
effectivement un problème qui est
important je partage tous les constats
je pense qu'on a tous le même constat
ici sur ces bancs on est même à la
limite aujourd'hui d'avoir des
fermetures de service il ya des services
meuf dans l'hôpital où je travaillais de
maternité ou qui ne fonctionne que sur
de l'intérim et des équipes d'intérim
qui se sont organisés en équipes et
rennes quoi c'est à dire que en gros ils
se sont toujours les mêmes donc ils sont
quasiment là
permanence donc c'est relativement
stable mais bien évidemment avec des
salaires qui sont hors normes
alors le décrite 2016-2017 m'avait
laisse un peu d'espoir en disant qu'ils
allaient avoir un plafonnement en
attente et d'exprimer à madame boutin
qui a eu un qui a eu quand même le
courage héros on se rappelle la violence
en fait qui a su qui a suivi cet
amendement on s'était dit qu'il fallait
que l'ensemble des ars jouent le jeu
pour qu'effectivement il y ait pas de
concurrence entre une région et une
autre région force est de constater que
ce résultat-là n'a pas abouti donc moi
je serais je vais voilà je vais voter
l'amendement du gouvernement
en me disant qu a priori je vois pas
enfin je la solution précédente n'a pas
fonctionné et battantes ont la solution
il faudra réévaluer les choses mais je
pense qu'on peut plus rester dans le
dense dans cette situation si le blocage
est a priori sur l'ensemble du
territoire français
bon après après ils iront peut-être
partir au luxembourg mais de façon ils
sont déjà partis au luxembourg je suis
frontalière on a déjà ce système là et
les médecins vont déjà où les
infirmières ont déjà cherché un meilleur
salaire ailleurs
moi je me dis que voilà aujourd'hui il
faut peut-être tranché et je vais voter
donc l'amendement du gouvernement sur ce
sujet en espérant avoir un retour quand
même régulier parce qu'en fait c'est pas
une question de posture autre chose
comme ça mais il faut il faut changer un
peu les choses
si chers collègues le président
karoutchi monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
une fois n'est pas coutume je ne vais
pas suivre le rapporteur et je voterai
l'amendement du gouvernement
je suis hypocondriaque j'ai deux frères
médecins ce qui n'est pas tous les jours
facile parce que plus vous avez de frère
médecin que si vous inquiète sur votre
propre sort donc comme en plus je ne
suis toujours pas vaccinées
vous imaginez bien mais
il me parle régulièrement de ce type de
situation et j'entends bien qu'on peut
trouver des solutions madame apourceau
poly dit contrôlons plus les agences
d'intérim
je n'y crois pas je préfère croire dans
les directeurs d'hôpitaux mais les
directeurs d'hôpitaux ont besoin d'être
protégés protéger avec ceinture et
bretelles pour ne pas être soumis à la
concurrence à la surenchère et c est le
meilleur moyen de ne pas être soumis à
cette situation c'est de prendre des
mesures qui font qu'ils ne peuvent pas
et qu'à partir de là les intérimaires
potentiels se disent c'est pas la peine
d'essayer
on ne peut pas et donc dans ces
conditions je trouve que cet amendement
est peut être très encadrée peut-être
trop encadrants mais au moins on peut
imaginer qu'il aura un résultat efficace
et concret et dans ces conditions je
voterai l'amendement du gouvernement et
je veux dire au ministre vous voyez
j'étais prêt assure le rapporteur
précédemment
comme quoi le débat parlementaire ça
peut servir merci chers collègues
malades
merci monsieur le président en 2017
quand je suis arrivé un petit peu du
jour au lendemain à la faveur de la loi
notre au sénat j'ai dû réfléchir sur mes
quinze jours d'astreinte en maternité et
donc je suis passé à une semaine je
divisé par deux et en contrepartie les
intérimaires qui m'ont qui m'ont
remplacé ont fortement pénalisé le
budget de l'hôpital
et là je me suis dit mais depuis 30 ans
j'ai fait faire des économies
considérables à l'hôpital en acceptant
des conditions parfois qui mettait qui
mettait
agréable parce que j'aimais mon métier
mais quand on réfléchit à tout ce qu'on
a balancé comme fortuna aux intérimaires
donc je serais pour une fois
effectivement d'accord avec avec olivier
ferrand
néanmoins le vrai problème finalement
est ce que ce n'est pas la bientraitance
des praticiens hospitaliers qui sont qui
sont en place
est ce que ce n'est pas le l'allègement
de la lourdeur administrative qu'on met
comme contrainte et quand on travaille
en maternité qu'on voit les conditions
de travail des obstétriciens mais
également des anesthésistes qui sont là
là ni pour les péridurales et et autres
effets est ce que est ce que finalement
le vrai problème il n'est pas en amont
sur le traitement correct des des
praticiens moi même ma collègue qui
travaille avec moi lorsque je suis
arrivé au sénat elle démissionné de ces
de ces astreintes parce que elle a été
créée de voir ce qu'ont donné aux
intérimaires
le vrai problème monsieur le ministre il
est là le problème
il est dans la bien traitance des
étudiants en médecine dès la première
année dont on voit actuellement les tous
les doutes les problèmes que posent les
conditions
à force il n'y aura plus de vocations et
on sera condamné à faire travail des
médecins souvent des mercenaires 1 qui
arrivent de partout en europe ou
d'ailleurs et qui viennent
amoindrir la qualité du travail
hospitalier
merci cher collègue madame jouanno mais
c'est le président merci monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
alors moi je voudrais remercier
finalement le ministre de nous avoir
fait partager l'ensemble de ces
réflexions acquis sont anciennes et qui
sont celles d'aujourd'hui
déjà dans la discussion générale j'avais
annoncé que le groupe centriste trouvé
que les mesures prises par la commission
des affaires sociales était en retrait
par rapport à ce que nous souhaitions en
réalité en écoutant le ministre nous
avons pris la décision les uns et les
autres de suivre la proposition du
gouvernement
moi je suis d'accord avec tout ce qui a
été dit en termes de constat de
diagnostic est ce que nous disait le
président karoutchi tout à leurs
protégés
les directeurs d'établissement mais
protéger aussi les présidents de conseil
de surveillance parce que même si les
uns et les autres trouvent que c'est
inconvenant de payer certains praticiens
mais au delà de du comment du réaliste
finalement par rapport au budget de
l'hôpital
eh bien ils sont obligés le faire parce
que sinon c'est la fermeture d'un
service et la fermeture peut-être de
l'établissement est en réalité ils
jouent ils jouent la montre mais à quel
prix
et je voudrais aussi dire combien c'est
ce phénomène de concurrence qui s'est
installée dans le pays entre
établissements et est difficile parce
qu'on veut aussi soutenir ces
établissements pour rendre service à nos
concitoyens et que la santé aujourd'hui
encore plus qu'hier et un des éléments
fondateurs de notre je dirais pacte
national
la santé c'est important et on défend
nos hôpitaux on défend nos services mais
c'est vrai que c'est un crève coeur de
dépenser autant d'argent pour pouvoir
maintenir des services
si on veut comment arrêter ce
mercenariat comme on l'appelle
maintenant je pense que il faut arrêter
les primes on arrêtera les chasseurs de
primes et je pense que la proposition du
gouvernement va dans ce sens
après on pourra en évaluer la portée
dans quelques mois ou dans quelques
années mais ce qui compte avant tout
c'est que nous atteignons ce système de
concurrence déloyale qui s'est installé
entre médecins dans certains
établissements
parce que comme le disait ma collègue
effectivement certains ont donné sans
comment exiger autant de salaires et
puis aussi la concurrence entre
établissements
mais attention aussi à la concurrence
avec les établissements privés
il faut aussi se poser cette question là
parce que si on veut avoir des médecins
de coeur il faut effectivement y faire
attention
merci monsieur daumier merci monsieur
présent merci au ministre pour ses
explications puisqu'on a échappé à une
clôture du débat après un mot
défavorable donc et ça montre l'intérêt
du débat qu'on aurait dû avoir depuis le
début de ce projet de loi sur un certain
nombre d'autres sujets d'ailleurs moi
j'entends le pari que prend le ministre
qui propose par le contrôle a priori et
les conséquences qui serait que les
personnes concernées bascule sur un
autre temps médical par contre ça c'est
ça le pari et je suis pas du tout
convaincu
on verra bien on verra bien mais
n'oubliez pas que le la sur rémunération
et on est tous d accord pour lutter
contre ce phénomène la craie du temps et
c'est ça le problème
mais c'est ça le problème c'est que ça
crée du temps médical supplémentaire et
qu'il faut rattraper ce temps médical
j'invite par ailleurs le gouvernement a
apporté une réponse puisqu'on n'arrive
pas à traiter ça dans les projets de loi
pour des raisons budgétaires à la
question des docteurs junior qui est une
problématique qui est ce contingent tu
as la même si ça n'est pas la même a
exactement mais qui est qui et
contingente nous n'allons pas voter
l'amendement du gouvernement et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi ils vous
invitent à ne pas le voter parce que si
nous votons conforme
la discussion est close et moi je suis
ce que propose aux rapporteurs de
terminer la discussion en cmp parce que
nous sommes prêts à suivre la logique du
gouvernement mme à l'exception d'un
point c'est la sanction financière des
directeurs d'hôpitaux qui
n'est pas indispensable qui n'est pas
indispensable et qui peut avoir un effet
même un peu paralysante et donc moi
j'appelle à ce qu'on discute ce point là
en cmp donc à ne pas adopter le texte
conforme maintenant à ne pas voter
l'argument du gouvernement demande du
gouvernement et à reprendre en cmp la
discussion sur la base que propose le
ministre en la modifiant légèrement
merci je connais monsieur savary merci
monsieur le président partage les propos
de bernard jomier je pense que c'est une
discussion relativement complexe il faut
beaucoup d'humilité
vous avez beaucoup de certitudes
monsieur le ministre nous y sommes
habitués il en faut il faut avoir des
convictions des certitudes mais madame
busin avait beaucoup de certitudes
également quand elle nous avait présenté
un dispositif qui devait régler le
problème
et puis 18 mois après on fait le constat
qu'il n'est pas réglé donc je serai une
approche moi un peu différente à savoir
que le texte du gouvernement règle
peut-être le problème des hôpitaux règle
pas le problème des epic règle pas le
problème des privés et en conséquence
que vont faire ces mercenaires ils vont
aller vers des cliniques privées qui
connaissent aussi les difficultés nos
congrès devra ils pourront pas
travailler en hôpitaux mais ils vont
aller ailleurs
soyons très attentifs à cela donc je
pense que ça mérite une discussion
approfondie la commission a réécrit le
texte qui permet évidemment de remettre
sur la table un certain nombre de
dispositions qui pourront peut-être
trouvé une solution qui conviendra à
tout le monde
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans ce
contexte particulier je serai j'aurais
tendance à proposer à mes collègues
véritablement de suivre la commission
pour que ce débat puisse derrière être
éclairé voilà pour ces mensonges
merci monsieur le président il faut
quand même rappeler quand même la
responsabilité politique de différents
gouvernements il faut dire pas que du
gouvernement actuel dans la situation
qui fait que nous avons 10% de postes
vacants que nous avons des centaines de
postes d'infirmiers vacant de praticiens
hospitaliers etc
donc ça il faut quand même le dire même
si maintenant les conséquences
complètement contre-productive nous
reviennent au visage et qu'il faut
effectivement cette eau je serais tenté
de voeux de vous alerter en amont sur le
fait que vous êtes en train de produire
la même situation dans le monde
médico-social
vous avez dans le monde médico-social
dans les services de soins infirmiers à
domicile est compris dans la branche
sociale de l'aide à domicile les vous
les avait exclues du ségur de la santé
et vous bloquez aujourd'hui tous les
agréments salariaux qui font que
désormais les aides soignants son père
est payé au smic alors qu'elle était à
20% disent mais qu'il ya quelques années
donc moralité
nous avons aujourd'hui dans les services
de soins infirmiers la montée de
l'intérim de façon brutale plus personne
ne rentre et effectivement nous avons de
l'intérim et vous aurez dans quelques
années vous reviendrez vers nous nous
disons il n'est pas normal que dans les
services de soins infirmiers à domicile
le déficit de ces cian porté à la rs et
souvent repris et qui équivaut à
l'intérim supplémentaire qui est passée
de zéro dans certains services à 10 à 20
à 30
donc vous avez exactement le même
situation dans les établissements dans
les ehpad
on a trouvé des ehpad à la ville de lyon
où 50% c'est l intérim
c'est les conditions de travail c'est
les conditions de rémunération et
aujourd'hui vous bloquer la
revalorisation ici et vous faites monter
l'intérim et après vous vous plaignez
des déficits vous plaignez des
mercenaires et c'est ce que je je tiens
à dire que l'intérim
même quand ils me respectent alors les
règles y aurait ou du commentaire là il
y en a pas pour les cciad
mais même quand il est presque normal en
temps normal en terme de rémunération
c'est quand même la culbute
deux fois plus que le prix des soignants
qui sont au smic et qui dès lors ne
supporte plus du tout et sortent des des
établissements alors si résolvez le
problème aujourd'hui que bien des
gouvernements entiers ou créé hier est
notée par dans le médico social dans les
services de soins infirmiers
ce cadeau mal vous essaierez de d'éviter
merci chers collègues chez nos porteurs
c'est effectivement un beau et grand
débat parlementaire et je pense qu'il ya
effectivement une urgence à régler ce
problème de l'intérim qui est autant une
question économique
une question de santé un finalement bien
sûr une question de santé mais une
question économique et moi je crois
qu'il ya des règles fondamentales et
quand l'inflation est galopante
il n'y a pas d'autre solution que le
contrôle des prix au moins dans un
premier temps alors ensuite il faut
régler le problème et ce sera la
deuxième partie de mon propos les
problèmes auxquels nous devons faire
face le gouvernement met le pays tout
entier et nous dans les territoires
c'est cette question de la pénurie de
médecins qui résultent on le sait toutes
et tous du numerus clausus mais on voit
bien qu'il ya une volonté politique qui
va il faut du temps bien sûr de faire en
sorte de remédier à ce problème mais il
me semble j'ai du mal à les identifier
c'est pas forcément le débat
d'aujourd'hui mais mais mais pour les
les temps qui viennent des rigidités sur
cette question informer plus et plus de
médecins et notamment des résistances y
compris dans dans les facultés des
résistances a formé plus de médecins et
j'ai du mal à comprendre dans un pays
comme la france
pourquoi on est soumis à ces résistances
bien sûr c'est pas du jour au lendemain
mais il me semble que nous ne sommes pas
en capacité même sur le moyen terme et
bleu long terme a remédié suffisamment à
ceux à ce problème et c'est qu'à cette
question au delà des hôpitaux des
déserts médicaux devient tout à fait
insupportable pour nos concitoyens et
devrait malheureusement avoir des
conséquences en aménagement des rythmes
du territoire rire et en termes de santé
assez grave pour notre pays je vous
remercie mais bon contrôle des prix je
crois que c'est une évidence merci merci
je reconnais que monsieur le ministre
vous souhaitiez vous exprimer trois mois
monsieur le président merci beaucoup
pour ce débat de fond pour le sénateur
monsieur le sénateur john il ya aucune
sanction financière sur les directeurs
donc si c'est ce qui vous empêche de
voter l'amendement du gouvernement on
pourrait le voter
c'est une saisine du tribunal me
administratif mais sans conséquence sur
le directeur on protège au contraire les
directeurs et n'ont jamais été protégée
comme ça parce qu'ils peuvent dire c'est
pas ma responsabilité je ne peux pas
vous payer je ne peux pas vous payez ce
que vous demandez pour les sénatrice
communiste du groupe communiste pardon
et apparentés je suis parent dont le
titre dit il et s'attaque à part dont un
sur les mesures d'attractivité vous avez
parfaitement raison c'est un corollaire
rendre le métier attractif à l'hôpital
le secteur de la santé avec
l'augmentation au champion vice est
sensible on augmente l'indemnité de
service public exclusif pour tous les
médecins qui ne font que du public à
l'hôpital public
ainsi un jeune médecin qui arrive
maintenant à l'hôpital
il est au minimum à 4200 net par mois
c'est pas mal en début de carrière est
au dessus de 6000 euros nets
lorsqu'il a avancé dans la carrière et
vous rajoutez les gardes les astreintes
qui sont également rémunérés
donc on a travaillé sur l'attractivité
de façon de façon conséquente
vous dites il faut agir sur les agences
vous avez parfaitement raison alors un
le droit assuré par anticipation votre
amendement d'après le droit elle est
déjà très clair les agences d'intérim
sont censés suivre la loi le code du
travail
or vous avez le droit de majoration de
10 % de mémoire ça date de 2012 mais
j'ai un peu de mémoire là dessus vous
avez droit à une majoration de 10 % 4
travail temporaire certainement pas de
majorer de 300% or donc la loi le
prévoit déjà et mesdames les sénatrices
voudrais vous faire part juste devant
une petite expérience vous dire que la
grosse majorité des contrats c'est du
gré à gré c'est pas on passe pas par une
agence d'intérim
c'est le médecin qui tapent à la porte
du directeur qui dit moi si vous avez
besoin de quelqu'un pour faire des
missions vous m'appelez
je viens du jour au lendemain par contre
vous avez vous payé de temps donc là
agir sur les agences n'a aucun intérêt
pour ces contrats et enfin j'avais
dénoncé dans mon rapport
une agence en particulier une boîte
luxembourgeoise dont il s'est avéré que
c'était une boîte postale
quand on a des sur place je suis allé
sur place avec une équipe de télé c'est
une boîte postale et même pas d'agencé
c'était l'un des grands recruteurs qui
fait venir des médecins d'étrangers en
france et j'avais été menacé de procès
en diffamation par cette entreprise je
voudrais profiter de l'intervention pour
dire que j'ai toujours pas reçu de
plainte en diffamation comme quoi a été
peut-être fondé mon intervention je vous
remercie
merci monsieur ministre donc je vais
mettre aux voix
l'amendement 129 du gouvernement avec un
avis défavorable de la commission qui
est pour
qui est contre
si s'abstient
il est adopté le temps que je pense
qu'il fait tomber le 130 il fait tomber
130 donc je mets aux voix l'article 10
qui est pour l'article 10 qui est pour
l'article 10 ainsi amendé bien sûr
qui est contre
attendez on va faire un assis debout
pour que ce soit bien clair
alors ceux qui sont pour se lève
merci vous pouvez vous asseoir ceux qui
sont contre se lève
bon là c'est très clair je vous remercie
chers collègues qui s'abstient l'article
10 n'est pas adopté
[Musique]